Film Courage: When you’re writing a
screenplay do you ever think about
the money you will make off
of it as you’re writing it?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter/Author: No,
because I already have a contract so I know.
Now a spec, yes you can have delusions
of grandeur as much as you want but after
years in the business you know the
realities of like okay but no you shouldn’t
write from a place of that you should forget
about all that like I said you should do
your best job ever if you’re paid $500
buck or 5 million bucks there should be no
difference in your desire because then what
you’re doing is you are chasing money. There
are other businesses to do that that are
far more lucrative than spending years of
your life toiling away and trying to have that
one… “This is the one that is going to do it!”
So no, you should just bathe in the creative
process and not…when you are writing your specs.
When you’re writing an assignment and you already
have a contract you know what you are making
and then it becomes stressful because you are
actually making something so you are like “Oh
shoot - this is due when? Ahh…this better be
good.” You know? This is what they are paying me
for so that comes at a different level when you
leap over into that different realm of working
like we discussed earlier about being creative
under a deadline than just toiling away you can
work, it’s great to work when you
want…you know my spec…I’m just doing…I’m
not working with anybody else this is all my
words…which it has to be to get to a certain point
absolutely but then you step over that line
into the other world and it’s like “Well,
we don’t like the ending.” And then it
becomes like they say in filmmaking a million
compromises to get something done and sadly
yeah, but to get something done is amazing.
Film Courage: And does that go back to
what we were talking about with the Tai Chi
or the Karate example which is part of it’s the
physical and part of it is the mental and maybe
that pressure and maybe this pressure of “I’ve
got to be creative and I’ve got a deadline” and
not cracking under that pressure?
Mark: Sure, it’s a lot of it. I mean tremendous
amount of this is mental at the end of the day but
then those disciplines you can fall back on
because you can get into this terrible wheel that
you’re not producing at the best level you can
because you’re too worried about the other thing.
If you just yourself and dive into the work you’ll
get it done if you’re not constantly worried about
“Well I’ve got eight days left.” Just do it.
Question for the viewers:
Do you think about how much money you
are going to make with your screenplay?